welcome back to CBS mornings we've got
an important and heartbreaking story to
show you now it involves children and
their families going hungry in the east
African nation of Somalia listen to this
statistic more than one-third of the
country's 5 million children under the
age of five are malnourished that region
is having its worst drought in 40 years
and half of Somalia is now close to
famine Deborah patta visited a hospital
that is working desperately to save the
kids lives and we have to warn you here
that some of this video is very hard to
watch
um everyday mothers bring their severely
malnourished children to this hospital
for treatment
they don't need experts an
air-conditioned conference Halls to
explain what they've experienced
firsthand it is getting hotter every
year the droughts more frequent and
after five failed rainy Seasons Somalia
is once again on the brink of famine
every child in this ICU Warden by DOA is
under five every one of them a victim of
climate change exacerbated by conflict
Dr Abdullahi Yusuf is trying to save as
many as he can it's not fair that I mean
this time I mean that people cannot have
access to health and food food of course
two-year-old Naima has defied the odds
what you are seeing is not third degree
burns but kwashiorkor a lack of protein
caused those weeping wounds which have
to be dressed every day back at her
bedside her prognosis is good she will
be moved from the ICU later that day we
hope so inshallah she will be fine
because we have it's a long road yeah
it's a long road we have actually we
have witnessed a lot of severe cases who
have improved
but there's no time
three moments later another new arrival
and another emergency two-year-old
Malian is fighting for her life her
oxygen level should be close to 100 but
the reading is just 37. she is bloated
from severe malnutrition her hungry body
turning on itself with her blood sugar
crashing she doesn't Flinch as the nurse
injects her with glucose malion's mother
fadhia Adan is sick with worry while
some members of her family can't bear to
watch anymore
we didn't know at the time that we were
capturing her final moments her final
breaths the next day malyon went into
skeptic shock hunger is all she has ever
known
and two days ago it was Hunger that
claimed her life
for CBS mornings Deborah patter baidoa
Somalia
well we did say it would be hard to
watch and it was certainly that you just
think with all the wealth in the world
that something would be done after
seeing something like that yeah yeah you
oftentimes talk about the little things
that we may take for granted here in
this country yeah well the government of
Somalia has hesitated to call it a
famine they don't want to use that term
yet that would unlock a lot of Aid I'm
sure the Us and other major countries
are looking are standing by available to
help